welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures
j ventures riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today we're talking to yish dixit the
ceo and co-founder of power play an
end-to-end construction management sas
platform that aids in the simplification
of communication and synergizing
collaboration within project teams in
the construction industry
in his capacity within the organization
he heads power plays corporate team
fostering both internal and external
communication implementing the company's
vision and evaluating the organization's
short and long term goals
overall each supervises the smooth
functioning of all departments while
overseeing the holistic development of
the organization
[Music]
each digit welcome to 20 milliliters
thank you so much for being here how are
you
i'm good thanks for having me michael
thank you very much for being here and
talking about your entrepreneurial
journey and and why you're doing what
you're doing uh you know really this is
what the show is about trying to uncover
why people do what they do and and what
is it that gets them so excited about
what they're doing yeah today you're the
air ceo of power play but you're you're
still entrepreneur that's evident from
your background and today you're looking
at construction tech and communication
inventory
and everything that has to do with the
construction so thank you very much for
being here yeah same here uh
really
really excited for the discussion you
are going to have
well i think we can get started talking
about you know you as a serial
entrepreneur you know it's hard enough
to go through this adventure once or
twice i believe it's been even more
times for you what is sort of
entrepreneurship for you if you had to
to think through your own personal
journey okay so
i feel entrepreneurs are
it's like economic scientists we are
trying out different things but in
business world it requires a lot of zero
to one artistic journey but
soon after that once you figure out zero
to one then you have to figure out one
to ten
and then hundred to ten two hundred so
the journey keeps on changing and i've
seen a lot of entrepreneurs who
really like the first bit of things like
the early part of how things are being
figured out and
that research part and like digging into
the problem statements and trying to
figure out the best solution but it's
not just about that i recently learned a
lot many other things that you need to
do so uh
i would say we are like entrepreneurs
are like economic scientists so let me
take you back to my journey uh the the
first fundamental reason when i started
up so i i i'm an engineer by
my education i i was in iit roorkee it's
a link renowned institute for
engineering students in india
i graduated i was a placer software devs
in an early stage fast growth startup i
left my job in a month
i didn't
i just
i just could not take the like accept
the fact that like i could i'm working
for someone else maybe that is just
personal to me but then i later found
out but up after reading
about different entrepreneurs like max
levchin of paypal
and others that somewhere in
entrepreneurs this inherent uh
mindset of not working for others and
maybe doing something on their own
and then this
unlimited curiosity about how to make
things work
uh i think that is what entrepreneurs
are about
according to me
incredible now obviously there's
you know you're mentioning this artistic
zero to one journey yet there's you know
there's infinite resilience and
adversity that you have to overcome what
has been your experience with that where
did you find major adversity on on your
own entrepreneurial journeys leading up
to now
yeah so
when i started to so my first startup i
started in 2015.
i was a very naive a young person wanted
to
start a company i remember pitching to i
think 63 investors and not getting it
yet
wow
and i remember man the 55th i think on
the 55th or 56th investor meeting
uh i felt pathetic i said man this stuff
why why do people do this
i was outside my co-founder and uh
we're discussing man let's let's just
let's just ignore this
uh so actually the meeting did not
really go well and uh
we were asked some questions that were
legit questions and we did not have
answers to those questions
and
when we went outside the meeting like
once the meeting got over and we were
feeling pathetic my co-founder said
let's ignore all of this and that's when
it
that's when this hit me that no man we
can't just think notice this is some
solid feedback coming our way and if we
would have heard this feedback in the
12th meeting
maybe we were not there for the 55th
meeting right
and that is when so this is the kind of
attitude which is i think like required
it's not just about hard work let's not
romanticize
the fact that you have to work hard and
like go 200 pitches and all that you can
make it work in the maybe 5th or 10th
pitch right or maybe you can make it
work without
doing all that uh making your hands
bleed sort of thing maybe and and i
think when i started up for the second
time a lot of these learnings were with
me and
i think it took six months or maybe less
than ten pitches for me to raise raise
uh a good amount of seat money and i
executed what i want to do so yeah means
uh it that adversity had actually taught
me to be smart to actually think six
steps down the line and take the right
decisions friend
incredible tell me a little bit about
you know your most recent venture you've
been running for the last few years
construction power play well where did
construction tech enter your life that
it made you want to tackle this problem
that's an interesting question so i have
no background in construction
right um so michael uh
when i feel that my last company uh
failed in a sense i had to shut it down
a lot of learnings but he had failed so
what i realized is
entrepreneurs really need to invest a
lot of time in choosing the right
property
that they would want to spend a long
time on right
and
having an idea about the problem if you
have personally faced the problem that
helps or not because obviously
perseverance is required and all that
but it helps a lot that if you
understand the problem
uh
when we started so
i particularly did not know what
business i will start when i left my job
in 2019 again
uh me and my co-founder we sat down we
made a list of i think 23 ideas uh all
of these from our personal experiences
uh
just before power play we made an app
which
uh
went through our emails and told us all
about our paid subscriptions so that you
can cancel the unwanted ones right so
personal problems that we have faced
sometime in our life and it has impacted
us we noted down all these problems
this problem was basically my parents
house was getting renovated i was in
charge to get that done nothing happened
in time nothing happened in budget uh i
was struggling on whatsapp groups my
contractor was not giving me the right
data that i wanted to
all of this happened and we kept a note
of this problem
and when we started so uh
the the idea was we were trying before
this it worked friends were liking it
but we did not see a big opportunity
when i say big opportunity maybe can we
be
a 100 billion dollar company someday
right and if you want to become that the
market has to be big in the next 10
years we did not find that really big
and that's when we came to this idea and
michael when we started talking to users
in this space oh my god
people did not have a solution to be
very like honest people were trying
their way
out and trying solutions like for
example in india specifically if you in
u.s the customers already have
sophisticated software solutions but in
india people just have whatsapp
and microsoft excel
there was no other software penetrated
in the industry and people were trying
their way out trying to find some hack
by using whatsapp pen paper and exit
and i was blown away because every early
customer was trying out something
trying to hire someone to make something
trying to use a solution
uh by customizing it etc and that was
the ultimate proof that these people
actually need something and uh we
converted our first customer and just
unfit my designs there was no software
actually
this is the product you will get and
once the person was converted we just
made that in two weeks
wow okay so so tell me a little bit
about the sort of the ideation process
from understanding the the pain point to
to actually creating those stigma
you know workflows and and onboarding
your first customer what was that
internal process like for you
so
when the so
there was a basic thing that we had so
it was our fifth or sixth idea that we
were trying out so me and my co-founder
shubham uh
we got experts in our approach
uh the the work was divided in a manner
that i used to go and talk to users and
he was the one who was was going to
quote whatever we decided and it was a
daily iteration so what we used to do
there was a fixed format of digging into
user's life it was a five-step
uh framework where we used to ask okay
if let's say if i'm digging around how
do you manage your project i would start
by asking what do you think is the
hardest part around managing your
project on a day-to-day basis and that
would give me the top of the mind
problem in user's mind right and then i
started digging not his opinions but
started asking about his experience so i
would ask
okay so if you face this problem
uh if you feel this is the biggest
problem tell me the last time you faced
it right um that would take me to his
life and he will tell the exact
instances not putting his opinions in
between right and that's where we
started understanding okay this is the
problem the user is facing the customer
is facing and then making solutions like
if you if you nail the right problem
making a software or a or an app for for
people like us is not tough so
that's how we
did the first weeks of iteration and
the the biggest challenge that found in
the first five customers was
frankly in construction uh the back
office teams don't really think that the
the site workers would would actually
use software they don't have confidence
on their tech savvy right
right
and so what what did and and what was
your impression on that on that sort of
trigger like from the get-go did you
were you were you optimistic that they
would from a consumer behavior
standpoint
so actually um
we did not know
when we started we thought we will make
it work and so when so when we converted
the first five five customers and
uh
the implementations were going on and
people were expecting that data would
come and all that
we realized that
uh there is some friction in the site
team's
mind to use the product and
that is where the major innovation that
we did in 2020 happened so what we did
is
uh we realized that the site team will
never use the app if it's not solving a
problem for them
not for their company but for them right
and one of their major
pain points was to make a daily progress
report or a weekly progress report
after all they do on the side they have
to go back to their home they don't own
a laptop they ask their son or daughter
to just open
ms docks and just put all these photos
from whatsapp in that talk and type some
text convert to pdf and then send that
pdf over whatsapp or mail to their boss
we made this entire workflow in a few
clicks
and that is when they actually started
using the product and
now the entire go to market is very
simple it's bottoms up site team starts
using the app
when they are heavily engaged our team
reaches out to their back office telling
them there's a product their team is
already using why don't you use the
premium um so how do you get the
how do you get this the people on site
to actually discover the product and
figure out you know that they can be
leveraging something new rather than
what they've already been doing with pen
and paper
so yeah uh this there's a very
interesting thing here uh
just a shout out to my team um
our instagram followers are going to
reach 1 million
actually
these people yes and all of these people
our supervisors project managers on the
site and if you see our content this
content is like pure side
site execution content it's talking
about bricklaying it's talking about
excavation it's talking so all of this
is very personalized to them uh that is
one of the major
uh
channels of awareness
about the product and obviously we do
outbound reach out through
campaigns uh
but yeah i mean that's how we do it and
uh
obviously now since we are scaling and
we are scaling revenues and all that so
we we are figuring out more channels
because we want predictable pipeline to
scale the reviews but yeah that's how it
did in the early days
wow a million followers on instagram
from creating
the targeted content that is relevant
for your end customers now i assume that
a lot of this content is not necessarily
it's not just about power play and and
the app it's about traditional things in
their day-to-day that they that are
relevant for them
yes yes yes absolutely
interesting and then you see sort of a
and and you see a conversion by them
and you know it's somewhere down the
line that they get interested enough
that they check out the description they
check out the company and then they
start using the app but but you want
something that's a little bit more sales
and data driven and
you know
intentional pipeline
yeah yeah so we have started working on
that last year but early six months
uh was about this
and incredible now as you're continuing
to develop to building other part of
what are some things that you've learned
about you know sort of your own
your own leadership style as you're
building these companies and you're
you're building these teams who who is
sort of yeesh as a leader
i'm i'm a very hands-off
uh
person
i don't i don't really
microwave so i
the people that i've hired this is not
their first startup uh
they have been working in startups and
uh they join powerban most of the
feedback that i get from this my
leadership team who has who's like at
least five to the next uh ten years
experience is that i'm really handsome
the thing that really matters to me is
the cultural and strategic alignment so
i meet my leadership every week once
and that one meeting with every
leadership uh a member
every leader
is around cultural and strategic
alignment so i and my job is to think
the next 6 months 12 months but actually
on ground execution is done by those
folks so
they come up with the next one month or
next three month challenges and the
problems that they want to solve and i
obviously i love solving problems so i
discuss with them and i help them around
but this six month or 12 month alignment
is brought by me so
when the direction is pretty clear and
tools and supplies are provided to your
team and they are internally motivated
i think people can do wonders
we as humans do what we really want to
do
and if you hire the right person they
will just do and there is alignment they
will just do what you had to do in the
first place
that's that's that's my style yeah i i i
try to enable people give them what they
need and just get out of there
and so if you looking at
you know what's been most successful for
you and determining
been
you know most meaningful and getting you
the right feedback on your products is
it more active feedback or passive
feedback in that
i guess passive feedback is more you
know feedback that you collect yourself
that based on usage rather than active
feedback is when you you know outreach
yourself to the customers to get it
okay so in the early days it was more of
an active uh where we reached out to
people
uh
sort of thing but
as we scale to more than 10 15 20
customers what we did is
uh
on the face we put an option to reach
out to the ceo so there was a whatsapp
reach out section where you can just
talk to me
and when we scale from 20 to i remember
5 000 customers
5 000 users
i was the one juggling in those messages
then i hired someone but
but yeah means once once we reached at a
particular scale a lot of users found
that
space to talk to the founders really
relevant in giving us feedback i think
users came up with different ideas you
can also do think about this our
approach was obviously to understand
what the problem is why are they saying
such things why do they want this etc
etc but that made it really really
transparent
uh users really felt the rate of
innovation
was pretty high with us and
they really loved the speed by which we
were bringing on the calling their
problems and bringing all the features
on the platform
incredible
if you're
thinking through the vision long-term
vision of power play
yeah what do you hope that this becomes
i usually compare this to
see in consumer tech things have really
evolved right when iphones and
smartphones came out in 2008
uh consumers like they were very less
people who were using iphones or
smartphones but the time they spent on
these platforms were tremendously high
it was in ours
right
something similar is
happening for businesses so
if you look at my power users
they spend more than an hour on the
product every day
right and
since we are vertical sas what we
envisage is that one day a construction
business will do most of its work
through the platform that we have built
we sort of will become an operating
system
software operating system for their
workflows right now we are just project
execution right we will go
pre-construction we will go post
construction we will get into finance we
will get into procurement but this can
only and only happen when the product is
sticky
so when you are a default os when people
spend time on your platform and that is
the reason we call ourselves a slack for
construction that because the use case
that we chose was communication it
happens hourly there is a possibility to
develop stickiness in such a
product so we started with communication
use case which is from sites to office
all of that communication is basically
done by whatsapp and now we will go in
deep
deeper in the workflows that are less
frequent but more important and we would
want to cover all the workflows in the
industry and then
uh not just sas we would want to
make money by enabling third party
suppliers third party software providers
etc on the platform
incredible well
it's a grand vision and yes thank you
very much for for sharing it with me and
for sharing you know a little bit about
your your passion and excitement for the
entrepreneurial world as a whole and
that that excitement is contagious at
the least so thank you very very much i
wish you best of luck with power play
and thank you for the time
thanks for your time michael as well
lovely talking to you
thank you very very much
you